[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, hands in.
On three, MIT.
One, two, three, MIT.
5...4...3...2...1
Past the barrier
Door is...
...wide open
[APPLAUSE]
Hey guys, should we
climb some stairs?
Let's climb some stairs.
We're done.
Oh yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
So we just survived our
week experience here
at the DARPA Robotics Challenge.
MIT I think has
come in sixth place.
After being about an
inch away from winning
the whole competition, our drill
slipped away from the wall.
Ended up being a task
we couldn't complete
and that cost us
the whole challenge.
We lost or first place spot.
We were on a first place run.
But I think we got to show the
world that a robot based very
much on autonomy was capable
of competing with the very
best robots in the whole world.
We were using all kinds of
teleoperation and humans
in the loop.
There were a few defining
moments this week.
On our first run, we made just
as a simple operator error
where we forgot to turn
off the driving controller
before we tried to
get out of the car.
We fell down, broke
our right arm.
But even though we planned to do
the entire course right-handed,
the algorithms and
the operators were
able to recover and do basically
the entire course left-handed
doing a seven point run with
eight points total in a very
respectable time.
It was awesome.
Awesome.
I couldn't be
prouder of the team.
The way they handled the
stress, the drama, the pressure.
The way they used
their brains to get out
of every inconceivable
situation.
I don't think there's
another group around that
could have solved all
problems we solved this week.
I mean, unbelievable debugging.
I mean, it's impressive. so
I'm really proud of them.
That close man.
That inch.